but the fact that you thought I mean
disrespectfully the lives the blood of
Palestinians is often times by
commentators and politicians regarded as
less valuable than the blood of
Israelis Islam net is raising funds to
establish a Masjid and Community Center
in Norway and they urgently need your
support this donation will be a sar for
you because every person that comes a
step closer to Allah through your
donation you will in be reaping the
reward click the link and donate what
you can
brothers and sisters and dear friends
this moment where George Galloway
absolutely owns Pierce Morgan why why is
Pierce Morgan always repeating that 7th
October was the greatest Calamity that
has ever hit the zionists or for that
matter we know Subhan Allah uh What uh
happened of the if if there was any
innocent people any if there was any
innocent people not military men
innocent people that were killed we
totally condemn it you know we are
morally consistent with as Muslims we
condemn any kind of innocent people
killing but we know that the Hannibal
directive that they have and admitted
they have themselves admitted the the
the Zionist well the left leaning
Zionist who put articles in the har
admitted that their firing killed them
and majority of them were military
personnel that killed those people but
here is this thing now we're going to
watch inshah because the blood of the
white the Western man the Western woman
and the Zionist is more important
because that's where they can go and
rescue forages and kill 200 Palestinians
they don't care they do not care about
the blood of the other yes this other so
here's what's happened let's watch for
ourself in do it with you and it's been
a sort of controversial thing people
have sort of mocked me for it but I kind
of think it's a good starting point that
to go back to October the 7th when you
realize the scale of what had happened
that day do you condemn what happened
that day well I I have to first correct
you on something it was by no means the
single biggest Slaughter in the Israel
Palestine chapter in one day in one day
uh in in fact in 5 hours uh with shaon
on the roof shining a search light into
the Sabra and chatila camps in Beirut
3,850 Palestinian women and children
there were only women and children
because the men had all agreed to sail
away to Tunisia as part of an American
broker deal now younger viewers will not
remember Sabra and shatila but those two
names are burned in the minds of those
those older and who care about it so
that's triple the actual death toll on
October the nearly 7,000 more were
wounded on October the 7th uh yeah but
the fact that you thought I mean this
respectfully that this was the biggest
single day of Slaughter is part of the
problem the lives the blood of
Palestinians is often times by
commentators and politicians regarded as
less valuable than the blood of Israelis
and that is exactly the point they do
not care that's why scums dirt bags I'm
holding myself back not to it swear at
these dirt bags uh people like this
scumback far right they justify they
justify can you imagine they justify
that because they have that scum Tommy
Robinson was saying that the Hamas the
The Killing that happened with the
Palestinian they're saying oh but who
voted Hamas in so basically he's saying
something that bin ladin said Abu Bak
uh the the leader of Isis said they say
they would attack the Western World and
we condemn that look at this look at the
at the disparity look at this the
contrast we as Muslims have condemned
that nowh in our text or Traditions ever
say for us for them to do that yeah for
us to do that Isis and alqaeda would use
evidences to attack them buting
civilians by saying what who are the
ones that are voting them in so they
would attack innocent men women
westerners walking around and we saw
this now ironically and this is the
reason why we say they are the two sides
of the same coin Tommy Robinson in a
video was saying that who voted them in
meaning he is saying that the
Palestinians should be killed because
they are the ones who voted Hamas in so
to his logic if Isis and alqaeda was to
go and Massacre his wife and their kids
and children his wife by the way that he
cheats on regularly by going to
prostitutes and as cocaine parties yeah
I will challenge him to a lie detector
test that he's never cheat on his wife
and well we know that he hits her yeah
and now he goes and sleeps around can
you imagine this is the and anytime
money runs out for cocaine he does a
appe oh I got arrested guys yeah anyways
so you can see that to his ideology to
his logic Isis and alqa going and
killing his family members are Justified
because he's justifying the kill of
Palestinians because they voted Hamas
you scumbag you got exposed
alhamdulillah that's why we say you and
Isis and abak badi you guys are the same
that's all I want to say brother and
sister inshallah as you can see he got
exposed once again Piers Morgan may
Allah bless you guys